>> Tom: ANTI-TRUMP HOLLYWOOD
LIBERAL DEBRA MESSING IS AT IT
AGAIN, FRESH OFF HER CALL TO OUT
TRUMPED DONORS, SHE IS RAISING
EYEBROWS FOR RETREATING AN
OUTRAGEOUS INSULT AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT'S FAMILY.
THE TWEET CALLING IVANKA TRUMP
AND JARED KUSHNER NATIONAL
SECURITY THREATS.
JESSE, I FEEL BAD FOR DEBRA
MESSING AND I WILL TELL YOU WHY
IN A MINUTE BUT LET'S MAKE FUN
OF HER FOR A LITTLE WHILE FIRST.
>> Jesse: WHY WOULD YOU GO TO
ME FOR THAT?
I THINK DEBRA MESSING SHOULD
STAY OFF TWITTER.
TAKE THE L FROM LAST WEEK, COOL
OFF, LISTEN TO YOUR GROUP.
YOUR ENTOURAGE KNOWS WHAT'S
BEST.
GO ON A HIATUS, COLORED WINTER
VACATION AND COME BACK REFRESHED
AND YOU CAN DIP YOUR TOES BACK
IN.
>> Tom: DOES SHE HAVE AN
ENTOURAGE?
>> Jesse: ALL OF THESE
HOLLYWOOD PEOPLE HAVE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW THAT.
SHE'S GOT PUBLICISTS, MANAGERS,
LAWYERS.
>> Katie: AND THEY ALL AGREE
WITH HER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tom: E MEMBER THE BOY IN
THE PLASTIC BUBBLE, THE JOHN
TRAVOLTA FILM.
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE WORLD
OUTSIDE WAS LIKE AND THAT IS
WHAT SHE IS LIKE.
SHE'S GOING TO CONTINUE DOING
THIS BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T KNOW
THE WORLD OUTSIDE HER BUBBLE.
>> Dana: ATTENTION IS A HELL
OF A WEEK.
LAST WEEK SHE THOUGHT SHE HAD A
GREAT WEEK.
DON'T YOU THINK?
IT'S GOOD FOR HER TENSION LEVEL.
>> Jesse: SHE LIKES THE
ATTENTION.
>> Dana: IT WASN'T LIKE I
TOUCHED THE HOT STOVE.
I SHOULDN'T DO IT AGAIN.
SHE WAS LIKE, I KNOW WHAT ALL
DO.
I WILL ADD THE PRESIDENT'S
CHILDREN.
>> Tom: DO YOU KNOW ANYONE
ELSE WHO IMPULSIVELY TWEETS TO
GET ATTENTION.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE LIKE THAT?
>> Juan: I AM STRAINING.
THIS IS ONE OF TOM'S QUIZZES.
LOOK.
DEBRA MESSING, JIM CARREY SAYS
SOME CRAZY STUFF.
I'M AMUSED THAT YOU PAY SO MUCH
ATTENTION BECAUSE I AM ON THEIR
SIDE OF THE AISLE AND I THINK
THESE PEOPLE HAVE NO RELEVANCE
TO A POLITICAL CONVERSATION.
TO ME, IT'S LIKE WHEN THE RIGHT
GETS FOCUSED ON JON VOIGHT OR
KID ROCK OR WHO ELSE DO YOU LOVE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO?
>> Dana: CLINT EASTWOOD.
>> Juan: KANYE WEST.
I'M THINKING I DON'T TAKE
POLITICAL ADVICE OR CONSULT FROM
THESE FOLKS.
I THINK IT BECOMES LIKE ANYONE
IN HOLLYWOOD WHO WAS A PLATFORM
WHO AFFIRMS MY POSITION, GOING
TO LIKE THEM.
ANYONE WHO CONTRADICTS ME, I'M
GOING TO SAY --
>> Jesse: WHEN CLINT EASTWOOD
WAS UP AT THE RNC DOING HIS
THING, YOU ARE ALL OVER THAT.
KANYE WEST, YOU ARE ALL OVER
THAT.
YOU DIDN'T ACT LIKE THAT WAS NO
BIG DEAL.
>> Juan: INVITED HIM UP THERE,
THAT WAS THE RIDICULOUS PART.
>> Jesse: I THINK HE WAS
INVITED.
>> Juan: BY THE REPUBLICANS,
BY ROMNEY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SO THAT WAS A
MISTAKE AND THEY SHOULDN'T OF
DONE IT.
>> Katie: THE ONE GUY IN
HOLLYWOOD WAS ACTUALLY A
CONSERVATIVE.
>> Juan: KID ROCK, TED NUGENT.
>> Katie: THE POPULATION OF
LEFTISTS IN HOLLYWOOD.
>> Juan: I DON'T SEE WHY WE
PAY ATTENTION TO ANY OF IT
UNLESS IT IS TO MOCK THEM.
>> Tom: WHAT IS THE
JARED KUSHNER THING?
WHO IS CALLING THEM NATIONAL
SECURITY --
>> Dana: SORRY.
>> Katie: I DON'T WANT TO TURN
THE SEGMENT INTO A WALKIE
SITUATION BECAUSE WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE HAVING FUN.
>> Dana: YOU AND I ARE VERY
GOOD AT IT.
>> Katie: THE SECURITY
CLEARANCE, WITH HOW THEY GOT
THEIR SECURITY CLEARANCES AND
WHETHER THEY GOT THEM BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT WENT AROUND THE
SYSTEM AND DEMANDED --
>> Jesse: BRINGING PEACE TO